so the response time here is about
three seconds or so and i want to speed
that up
thank you
what's going on everybody and welcome to
a video where
yet again it will be a sundeck snickers
video uh
playing with when i think i can be
uh at least at the very basic level a
end-to-end chat bot with audio input
from you
the user and then audio output from the
machine now
there are many things we could change
along the way
and the kind of heart of the chat bot
would be whatever the
you know natural language processing
chatbot
um logic is right
uh and i am working on that of on my own
but i also stumbled upon
this dialog gpt so it's this dialogue
based
gpt model uh that is based on reddit
i will admit i have i've seen a little
bit from it
i don't think it's i think it's been
cleaned up
[Music]
it seems to be a very um well-behaved
bot
uh so i'm not i i wish it was a little
more spicy
but uh it's a very good chatbot um
so i think that's what we're going to
use at the heart
of the bot and then now it's just a
question of stringing together
um the speech to text then run the
speech to text through
dialog gpt and then uh text to speech
back out
and boom you have a live uh chat bot so
how cool is that i just want to see um i
want to experience
the kind of like live chat bot you know
via audio
um this is not something i've ever had
besides maybe siri
or your you know amazon alexa that kind
of stuff um
i've never been able to do it myself so
um so yeah let's uh let's go ahead and
get started
again uh kind of like the other
tinkering episode
this is going to be mainly a lot of kind
of um
hacking around um and just like copy and
pasting chunks of code from various
places
to get this just to work and then from
there we can kind of fine-tune it and do
arguably all kinds of really cool stuff
so
maybe more to the series uh will come
but to start
we want to get this dilo
gpt and check it out so
first order of business is this is
located on
hugging face now i'm sure many of you
guys are familiar with hugging face
i think hugging face got real popular
while daniel and i were writing neural
networks from scratch hashtag
nnfs.io by the way um
and so i just kinda i didn't have time
to really look into it and then
also no offense to anyone at hugging
face but
i hate your name i just i hate the name
hugging face and so i've just always
kind of
ignored this website every time it comes
up i'm just like
um but it's it's a very good a very good
website and i'm sure there are plenty of
people who absolutely hate the name
syntax as well so
you know whatever so so um anyway we're
gonna get
dilo gpt from hugging face and from what
i can tell and understand hugging face i
believe it's purely transformer
models um a lot of like language models
stuff like that and the models you
are like hosted on hugging face and then
you use
the transformers package which is
i believe hugging faces package i hate
that name
um anyway um i think
right i'm no expert on hugging face
that's for sure
um but i will say despite the silly name
uh
it seems like a pretty cool website
so we're going to grab uh this dilo gpt
so it's actually super simple you're
just going to pip install
transformers and then this is the one
that we want
and then if i scroll down somewhere
right this is
all the code like once you have the
model
you just run the model with this code
and again that's why
golly it's so simple so
um and then obviously you would need pie
torch um again these these
tinkering episodes i am not doing
everything and showing you how to
install
torch all that stuff by now there are a
million tutorials so if you need help
installing or
doing pip install transformers um i
you can you're gonna have to find that
so so anyway
it's as simple as taking that code and
so we'll come over here
and i am going to touch um
one uh we'll call it getting started.pi
i'm just making this file
for us uh and then i can open that up
let me pull this over here
and paste in that code now i've actually
already downloaded this so it should
hopefully
fingers crossed work out of the gate
now of course that never actually works
so
let's see what actually happens i'm just
trying to make sure i get this nice and
full screen
ah perfect and then let's go ahead and
make the text bigger so everybody can
see it okay
so uh we'll go ahead and save that and
in fact
um what did i do what did i do with the
uh directory there
there it is i'm gonna pull it down here
um i think we'll run it from a terminal
just
to be sure everything is working as
expected
so uh let's do python three
one getting started again if this is
your first time running it
chances are it is going to um
oh a couple of things first off let me
also watch invidia
smi let me pull this over i want to say
i'm guessing it's not going to run
immediately
on the uh on the gpu
that's usually how like models don't
usually by default run on the okay so we
got the thing coming up
so let me make the text a little bigger
hello
general kenobi better be the response
dang it oh you know what i think it's
supposed to be hello there
let's see if we can get it whatever
um let's see hello there hey there um
okay
how how are you
so yeah response time here is about i
don't know three seconds i'm just
kind of counting in my head um i'm great
how are you
[Applause]
so typing just sucks right it'd be so
much nicer if we could just speak
to um over the mic so anyway this
is dilo gpt and again it's been trained
this has been trained
on uh reddit conversations so like trees
of reddit conversations so
if you do something like um
do you like star
wars i do oh shoot
okay we'll restart it real quick i just
want to show you that it does know
history
and of course since this is going to be
a live demo it's probably going to screw
up um
and then while we wait on that um i
think
i'm trying to decide like how i want to
uh we might just leave it on the cpu for
now but later
you can it's something you wow shoot now
that i think about it
i think this is using torch hold on uh
do you like star wars
i like star wars what do you like
about it so hopefully it'll be something
star wars related i like the
characters so at least it knows okay
it's a movie it's characters it's a
story characters and so on
um in the in the past i asked these the
same like series of questions and it
said it liked the lasers
so it just depends on what's what's the
history so
uh for now we'll break out of this so
that's that's the internal bits of the
chat bot you can
you can tinker with it more if you'd
like it's
pretty cool to be honest um
and unbelievably simple to grab this i
mean come on
um it's
like i'm just i'm baffled at how simple
um
using that silly named website is but
cool so now what we want to do is we
want to take this as the internal guts
and we want to wrap
um around it taking microphone as input
and then um in the way that and
transcribing right so the microphone is
input has to transcribe that to text
we're gonna use jarvis
i think we've done a few videos on that
by now so you've seen that work
uh so we'll do that and then um once
we've translated that to text
feed the text through this chat bot and
then once that's done just use text to
speech
again uh i'll probably use jarvis i have
poked around a little bit for other
text-to-speech because i'd like to have
more voices
as far as i know the only jarvis voice
is like that stereotypical kind of um
lj speech data set voice and it'd be fun
to have other voices so
um i am kind of poking around mozilla
has like the
craziest looking text-to-speech library
i think i've ever seen
um it just looks like quite a bit to
learn so
we'll see um but anyways so yeah that
this is pretty cool we're off to a good
start
and i think um i think at least
what i'd like to do is take microphone
input and get to
um a response from the microphone input
so
uh coming over uh
yeah here i thought i had a directory
somewhere
with the yes
okay cool so uh let's just do original
um maybe i'll just copy them in here
yeah i think i'll just copy me no i want
to keep it organized
original jarvis files
and then let's just copy those
boom okay so we've got a few things here
the first thing that we're going to do
is the transcribe mic so um
there's kind of two things that you can
do you can do like this offline
transcription and then you can do
like from a file and then you could do
transcription live from the microphone
and um i like the live one
so this is the one that we're going to
use and quite literally
i think all we have to do again like
we've done before
it's just merging these two things
together so rather than text input so we
come down
where is our text input anyway it'll be
some sort of input
oh no oh my gosh my brain is already
failing me we've
we've not even gotten started um this
would take the input this is transcribed
mic so it's just whenever the mic comes
in
and i would propose
the point at which we need to transcribe
is going to be
in this listen print loop and then
if not result is final it just does all
this but then
here this is where uh we will once it is
the final
um that's what we want to pass in and i
think that will
work good enough because i it seems to
know like
it seems to know when um
and in fact let's just do it really
quick it seems to know when you're like
done
talking i don't know what they're doing
in the back end but it seems to
understand
as you're talking to just like keep
trying to generate the audio and then
when you're done
it's like okay done and like if there's
a long enough space of like dead
um dead noise i don't know
i could think of a good word for that um
anyway uh
so let's just do transcribe oh wait
python3 and let's zoom in a little bit
so people can see
uh transcribe mic
and then server dgx a100
oh my gosh i think that's everything we
need
wow that is so fast okay so then i'm
gonna wait for a second
and then it's done and you can see like
it just finished and took us to a new
line
and then it does a spam thing that it
does sometimes
okay so it's at that point that's when
like when it took us to that new line
i believe that's this else statement
right here
um so that is where we take our
transcription and then we feed it
through the chatbot and hopefully we get
an answer
so um
arguably we just copy and paste this
code
into here and
here's how i'm going to do it i'm just
going to make a ton of space real quick
come over here control a thanks
uh control v here uh we'll fix
this paste up that
and then here
um
okay so this one will be somewhat
challenging-ish
uh so what happens here to understand
like one we could just toss history we
don't even have to use the history
but the history is kind of cool that it
like remembers what you've been talking
about so
you wouldn't want to get rid of that
because that's a really cool aspect but
you could and you could just reset it
every time but essentially the history
is controlled by
this line right here right so it's
tracking the step that we're on so if
we're on step zero
it's basically going to tokenize the
input that like as we speak it's going
to
or as we input text in this case
it's going to tokenize that text and
either it's going to input
the new tokens right because it's just
going to concatenate here
these two things together or if it
doesn't have a history
right if they're just you know they're
using the step number to just know
is there a history uh and if there's not
a history then it's just boom we'll use
new user ids i kind of think you i think
the smarter way
about this would have been to maybe make
chat history ids initially empty
and then you would just keep cat i'm
sure there's a reason
i don't think the people at microsoft
don't know what they're doing so
i don't know um it just seems like that
would be better than you would
you wouldn't need to be tracking step
here
right it would save you a whole line
well not a whole line but it would save
you the if statement i suppose anyway
not important so what we're gonna do is
um
i don't know how we're going to retain
that history but we'll we'll
we'll figure it out as we go so first
i'm going to cut this we're going to go
up here
and post
that and then come down here and
essentially
for step and range so this like loop
that's going on um
i think we can cut that and then we'll
just come up here
and paste that there
i don't know if you guys have noticed
but i really i enjoy
uh showing everyone that like this is
legit like what i spend a lot of my time
doing just trying to figure out
make stuff work this way and it's a lot
of fun where's this code okay so we're
gonna get rid of that
uh probably should have saved that but
uh like in some sort of file so we could
reference it again later just in case we
need it but i think we'll be okay
so uh oh did we what did we do here do
we i think we replaced too much on that
i was too busy yicky acting i think we
yeah why did you do that uh we want it
here
okay so break this over
okay so then so this is
this okay so all that's getting input
into um into this chat bot
is just whatever the user input via text
well rather than inputting via text we
want the transcript press
plus overwrite characters so we'll just
print
we'll say mic
in equals
that pasta and in fact where's our uh
yeah hmm i kind of want to bring in my
cur my uh
my curses or curtsy's uh friend
this is my new favorite import for
everything so so curtsy's format
functions
red bold green on blue yellow cyan
and red blue okay oops
so let's come down here and just to make
it clear
print um
[Music]
so i'm gonna actually do this
print string
green mic in that's probably already a
string but just in case it's not boom
um like i don't understand like what's
overwrite characters so
i'm kind of curious
i don't know i'm not going to sit here
long enough to figure out what that is
but that doesn't make sense to me
so okay whatever um
okay so that'll print out in green what
we're going to put into the mic
and then basically and in fact
let's do this let's make this make sure
that is a string i'm sure it is but just
to be safe
um
green mike in and then so mike in then
comes here
there okay so then uh what's going on
here just for the record
is it's essentially encoding whatever
you
input the text that you input and then
it adds this end of sentence
token and then it um
it's just tokenizing that if you have a
history
it's going to essentially append to that
history
with this line if you don't have a
history
then what you input is just what you
just you know input here
and then you feed it through the model
it generates a response and that
response is in theory like it's all it's
tokenized or it's encoded
into these like um numerical
label not labels i don't know it's
tokenized okay
numerical ids is probably the best way
to call it
and then at the very end when you want
to see it in actual real language
it gets decoded and then you're just
decoding the output
um up to probably the
you know it's just going to keep
generating until it reaches this like
end of sentence token
that the model learns to output and say
hey that here we're at the end now
so if you were to sit uh if we set this
to false you will probably see
literally end of sentence uh like this
little token for the end of the sentence
but we'll leave that for now i don't
think i'm gonna change that um
okay so we've made our changes let's see
if if we're done
um like chatbot um oh wait we have this
one here yeah
so oh we're gonna need the server do we
have that
okay we do i think we're good to go
i don't know uh python3 one getting
started
and then we just need to specify the
server is the
dgx a100
omg no
254. oh did we leave that little snit we
did
um and then listen print loop
where does that get called again here
with microphone
listen primaloo okay i think that'll be
good enough
uh where is where's my console
cool let's try again
hello how come the other one started the
other one when i did the mic
oh is this maybe loading the model
that's probably what takes a moment
oh my gosh
uh didn't we bring that in
oh god
i knew i knew i hit my middle mouse
button it was this yeah sorry
i knew i hit my middle mouse button and
uh
i looked to see like oh did i paste
something i didn't see it but
anyway that was just a stupid i typoed
basically testing
we know the step of course uh i will do
you guys a solid and hopefully i'll
remember to edit out these weights
um okay so step how do we want to do
that
i i'm pretty sure the
loop is is always inside of this
function
so for
oh gosh four response in responses then
it goes here
man i can't decide how i want to handle
for that
so i think at the at the very beg basic
level
i think we can get away with just
passing here step
equals zero and we'll i i think that
will
be okay so let's let's just keep taking
swings until we get a hit
okay here is another test
hello how are you doing today
we did it doesn't that look cool so
um i guess are we waiting i'm not sure
uh okay so that's pretty cool um
i'm gonna go ahead and break it here yes
that's fun isn't that i just i don't
know that just gets me all giddy inside
and how easy was that we did this in
what
23 minutes and i probably could do it
faster um
and arguably i mean that was what like a
couple of moving some code like three
times
um making a quick fix and then boom done
um i guarantee you there will be lots of
little issues with this as time goes on
but what a great start oh what a great
start
oh i get that just makes me so happy
it's so cool to like talk into the
microphone and then get the response and
then now
what we have to do and i think i'll do
it probably in the next video
is um um
[Music]
we need to do audio output right and
then once we have audio output
uh it's like a full we've done it like
it's a it's just this full end-to-end uh
chatbot that you can like literally talk
to
and uh this was quite fast um
where do i hmm that is one thing i
wouldn't mind
uh possibly fixing i'll remove the wait
time here hopefully
harrison and editing don't forget remove
that hey what's going on how are you
doing
i'm doing well thank you for asking
so the response time here is about three
seconds or so and i want to speed that
up
thank you
okay cool um yeah let's go ahead and uh
let's fix that real quick uh and the fix
to that is actually super
simple ish um i
try to decide what i want to do i think
i'm going to copy
pasta uh where's rename
am i blind i guess i misclicked it okay
uh dot dialogy pt testing
um well i think what we want to do is
where
is my cool
um take this
so copy that begone
pasta got a little too excited with our
copy that's okay
uh and
[Music]
with torch it's like this like
um it's one of the things i don't like
about torch whereas like with with
tensorflow
you literally just do like with
tf.device and then it's like
uh was it slash gpu and then you pick a
gpu
and then you know call in and then
bada boom bada bing you're done
not so with pi torch um it's a little
more annoying with pi
torch let me see if i can find the uh
it's like you got to do like dot
and it's like two device and then you
have to pass like a device
object maybe i don't know i gotta i
gotta figure this one out um
let's see
uh pie torch
device choice i don't know pi torch
uh how about pi torch run on gpu
where's the code bro dot two
oh interesting so can i just say dot two
cuda
is that gonna work
uh okay so i think what we need to do is
send
um
we definitely want the model tok the
tokenizer probably doesn't need to be
but the model needs to go
dot two can i really just say cuda
[Applause]
i don't think that's gonna work but if
it does cool
uh tokenizer dotting code i don't think
i want to encode but i do want the model
generate
and then the tokenizer decode i think
the tokenizer can stay
cpu that's like a quick look up and it's
only like i think a
uh vocab like 50 000 or something like
that so
i don't that should not be slow what
should be slow is probably the model
so um python 3
what is this dial law okay so it's going
to take a minute for this to load but
then once it loads and then also
watch nvidia smi
we want to make sure that one of these
gpus actually loads
up
maybe two gigs
five gigs okay looks like the model's
about
well we were already at a gig so um
maybe four gig model
uh and then if we say hey what's up
you little what
model generate dot 2 cuda what's your
problem bro
okay let me think about this for a
second so dot 2 could so that definitely
worked it loaded up our model
i think what it's getting angry about is
this
these user inputs are not on the model
so i'm going to say 2 cuda there the
concat
operation i don't think that would
require a 2 cuda
but then model generate would needed to
cuda
which we already have
i don't think we're going to need it to
cuda on that let's go ahead and test
that though and see what happens
hey what's up not much you
how's the weather right okay so
as you can see this response is not
three seconds anymore
this response is like bang done so um
that's a bummer like watch out fast
enter boom done
oh here's a good that's a good example
too of the history right like cold and
raining that's a bummer yeah it's been
raining for a few days now
um yeah that's wow
that is so cool and we literally just
grabbed that in like one second
i just think it's so hilarious how
quickly i have i
if only you knew how much i've struggled
with making like a reddit-based chatbot
and then
i grabbed this in like two seconds it's
it's funny to me anyway uh okay so
that's way quicker
so now last thing before i end out the
video
is let's port over the moving to cuda so
that's not too hard right to do dot 2
cuda
but again gosh it's just so much easier
to just like wrap everything with the tf
device
and that's only if you need to use a
specific device like it's going to
automatically go to your gpu
you don't have to say like each each
individual line
where you got to do dot 2. um
okay so i'm going to get over here
i'm going to just do this i know you
guys can't see the one that's on the
left but i'm just go i'm just porting
over the changes that we just made
uh as soon as i find it
um wrong file
isn't it fun it's so fun uh okay so
dot two and then here will be quita
cuda and then we'll come down here we
are almost done
uh this is dot to
uh cuda and then a little late should
have done this a long time ago
copy uh the cat we don't need paste it
there and i think that's it
and boom now we should have a
really fast how dare you send me a text
uh we should have a very fast model so
let's go ahead
and test that
i'm gonna open yet another terminal
because why not it'll be easier than
finding the one i was working in
uh so python three one getting started
and then we need the
server dgx a100 oh my god
and then we'll get things started and
then we'll be done after this
hey there how you doing now
um i kind of want to do one more thing
and change his color to like orange
or blue or something
he thinks it should be red so we'll
we'll make him red or her
oh this chatbot just i it gets me i just
gets me um okay uh how do we do this dot
format i don't think we can wrap that in
red
um
um okay so one more little tinkering and
then really we're done we're done after
this
we still have to do the audio out but
anyway it's just straight up
from here it's just like text to speech
boom done i mean that's
it's just so cool like how quickly you
can dev this stuff
uh so the output uh print
tokenizer dot decode
so really we would just say
output equals and then this i would
probably clean this up further but
that's okay
uh red
output
i'm not going to be heartbroken over an
extra space there might actually be
useful so
why is it still at five gigs didn't we
break it
although i have a ton of windows open
maybe i left one open
i have no idea
okay uh let's just rerun this that's
kind of weird though why is that
still at five i swear i closed them but
whatever hey what's going on do you like
your new colors
okay i get it you like the new colors
very cool what's wrong with the logo
okay maybe we'll make it a little
smaller
okay you get the idea pretty cool um now
all we're gonna do next i'll try
uh i'm gonna try this
okay it's so fast at response
i just think that's so cool like how
quickly we can get a response and
a lot of them have been pretty good
responses too
same same
okay that's all for now uh in the next
video we'll actually give it a
voice if you have questions comments
concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
i will see you guys in the next video
ugh
you